[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number
54. we are more than a week
post-election is that oh yes
right that's amazing we survived this
long so that's something of an
accomplishment congratulations
to you too um yes so i'm um
i'm wearing a bandana and one could take
that to be
a um response to the fact that covet is
now
very much again on the rise but it isn't
this time i'm just wearing it because
i'm i'm feeling uh you know in kind of a
bandit mode abandoned mood yeah
no it would make no sense for you to be
wearing a bandana in our home
with the four of us and our friendly
quadrupeds
uh in order to avoid covad unless one of
us have been exposed in which case
um probably we should be being more
careful than this so
yeah bandit huh yeah so you want to talk
about that well i don't know i guess
it's been kind of a brutal
week on uh social media and
unfortunately social media is playing a
larger role in our lives as a result of
the
reduced activity in the world and
increased fears of this new wave of
covid
i will say as long as we're on the
coveted topic there is
um lots of gearing up for what sounds
like it might be a renewed
uh i hate the term lockdown right i
think it's actually a bad term
a renewed um quarantine
also not a good term because we're
talking about keeping people who are
healthy from interacting but
in any case there is um
i think a tension between the political
dynamic that has unfolded around kovit
and the fact that there are effectively
teams which there shouldn't be
and the question of what the hell are we
going to do about covid now it may be
that this new vaccine
is um is the silver bullet
but i have to say we should have done
the quarantine thing right at first we
should have done it much more
intensively for a short time and to the
extent that we are now talking about
that i hope that people who've become
very skeptical about interventions will
consider the possibility that for
our well-being going forward collective
and individual
that it may be that a brief intense
period
of suspending non-essential activity
might be the key
well i suspect that you and i actually
at this point come down somewhat
differently
as to what the appropriate response
societally would be um
what we're about to see here in oregon
is there's
uh governor brown established something
that she called a pause for two weeks
i don't remember what all the specifics
involved in that were but it involved
backing off of some of some of the
things that were open
and yeah we never as i assume everywhere
but i'm not actually sure
we never became fully open you know our
kids haven't seen the inside of a
classroom since
march you know all of this and you know
there's of course no
no live events no music no theater no
sports uh swimming pools have been
closed all of this
um but she's in i don't know it's three
days from now there's going to be a two
week
something more than a pause i don't
think she's using the word lockdown
but in which once again there's no in in
restaurant dining
all the gyms are going to be closed all
the museums are going to be closed
and so far what i've said you know
may make sense given that oregon like so
much of the country right now
is experiencing a surge
in in cases although interestingly
um the deaths are not keeping a pace
right the the cfr seems to be the the
case fatality rate seems to be changing
the longer it is that humans are
interacting with this thing
as we would expect as we talked about
back in march april may when we were
talking a lot about covid
for multiple reasons both because we're
getting better at dealing with it and
because there may be an evolutionary
transition
between us as hosts which will be slow
uh and in the the virus itself which
would could be
quite rapid right so it could be coming
less virulent which would allow it to
stick around with humans for longer
you know effectively become something
that we were more willing to just have a
sort of background level
noise um and you know and of course
there's also the real possibility and
some people say this is hurt immunity
but i think this is a misunderstanding
what hurt immunity is
um is just that you know the the people
who were most susceptible both to
getting it
and to experiencing quick death from it
um have largely already been affected
and so the people who are getting it now
may well have long-term negative effects
um the full extent of which we have no
way to know yet uh
but they are perhaps less likely to be
the ones
to get it and die quickly because it has
already affected those people
that part of the population especially
since we see a correlation between uh
susceptibility and severity yeah um so
yes you would imagine that this thing
would
would pick off people who were
vulnerable for whatever reason
first leaving a less vulnerable
population on the other hand the numbers
of
people who apparently are positive for
this at the moment are pretty staggering
oh it's huge you know so oregon
experienced more than a thousand new
cases a day
two days running at least this week
which oregon has always been interesting
throughout this pandemic in that while
california and washington were
epicenters in many regards oregon was
actually
among the lowest uh had among the lowest
number of cases in the country
and um also tellingly
uh despite the amazing number of
protests
and continuing amazing number of riots
that have been happening
depending on how you count every day or
nearly every day since the end of may
those don't seem to have been
attributable
to uh super spreader events or or
rising or even even clusters of cases
and you know to this point the point
that we've been making from the very
beginning
there is scant evidence that this virus
transmits effectively outside
that airflow and boundary layers
are key to understanding what it is that
you are likely to
to need to think about in order to stay
healthy and maybe not a hundred percent
never having been in contact with the
virus but very low
dosages of this virus may in fact
provide a small level of inoculation
against getting sicker
yes and um i will say i think what
we were intuiting and interpreting from
what we were reading early on
has been borne out almost entirely the
exception being we were
afraid like everybody else that fomites
the surface transmission
was going to be a big deal turned out
it's not a big part in this case
so i uh early on decorated
most of our outdoor door knobs i i
bought and
applied copper tape just figuring well
we're going to wash our hands but also
copper
viruses and chronoviruses in particular
are known to
die faster deaths on copper than on
stainless
and so copper is a is a good antiviral
and antibacterial surface
but it doesn't it doesn't seem like that
is
a necessary step here yeah but the
i think the important lesson as i see it
is that a
a lot was deducible from the high
quality information and there was a lot
of low quality information circulating
with it but if you
paid attention um it was possible you
know
what percentage of a highly effective
vaccine
is the what percentage in terms of worth
is a high quality model of how it
transmits and what you can do
to not eliminate but reduce the chances
in each and every
instance in other words if you get into
a car
that somebody else has been driving for
whatever reason
or you get into a car you know if you're
using an uber or something like that
all the difference in the world rolling
down the windows and making it
effectively a high volume
space even if the person has been
coughing out covid
you can clear that volume very quickly
yes and so because it doesn't seem to
land and rest on surfaces very well
right it doesn't ever happen or it
doesn't get transmitted once it's landed
um yeah so there's you know we also
specifically said you know as
as folks on the right typically
were arguing that these protests were
going to cause a massive wave we
specifically said
maybe not because high volume spaces on
the other hand there were things that
went in the other direction like
shouting
and a few times that we went down there
you're seeing the number of people who
were shouting in each other's faces
like okay let's get out of the line of
fire of the shouting right right
well and also you know um i don't think
almost anybody was paying attention to
it but
being on the move right what we learned
from the
rapidly emerging data on the topic was
that
a healthy person exposed briefly to a
cloud of covid doesn't tend to get sick
it's only when you're
in prolonged exposure which of course
makes cars ultra dangerous planes
very dangerous rooms somewhat dangerous
especially if
people have been in them singing or
stuff like that well i will say so you
know we are not
our plan was not to talk about covet
today so i did not have any of this at
my at my fingertips and i do want us to
go to where we talked about going but
um it does seem to me that there is um
pretty good evidence at this point that
planes have been
made much more safe than uh than people
have imagined in fact i've had two
different people
um who've been on planes recently
uh tell me that both from the research
they did in advance and just their
lived experience right their experience
of being in the airports on both ends
and the plane in the middle
was that the plane everyone was being
careful if we are to believe that the
hvac
on border i don't know it's called hvac
on a plane but you know that the
filtration on board is as good as we are
being told it is
and everyone is wearing a mask at all
times that the planes
seem pretty safe whereas the airports
themselves do not now when i first heard
this i thought
airports are really big volume spaces
yeah there is an
awful lot of space to see links high
ceilings so actually airports don't seem
like they would be
uh particularly dangerous to me but in
both of these cases anecdotes
um the the it was both women they said
as soon as we got off the plane there
were people who we had been i
you know two different two different
situations who i've been traveling with
who ripped off their masks in the
airport
and uh and were you know other you know
either because they needed a smoke or
they were
whatever it was or because they just
thought it was insane that they were
having to wear a mask
such that suddenly in the airport itself
which also
presumably is less focused on how
perfect their air filtration systems are
uh is are maybe more in fact more
dangerous than the actual plane rides
interesting so my sense is
that a good model which isn't that hard
to convey once you figure it out it's
hard to figure out what the model is at
first but
a good model is worth some large
fraction of a vaccine maybe it's 25
right that the amount you can do to just
limit the number of places in which you
could even contract it
is pretty high if you're vigilant about
depending on how good the vaccine is it
could be worth considerably more than
that
right exactly and it's a lot less risky
that's for sure the things you do
in order to prevent this are safe right
although okay so you know again this is
this was not going to be the
the stuff we were talking about today
but um one of these women i was talking
to this week who who we know somewhat um
not very well
um came to me and said i've been meaning
to ask you guys and she just happened to
reach me and not not you you know as
biologists
what like what do you think of the
vaccine like is it
i'm hearing from anti-vaxxers i'm
hearing from people
who are who are saying they won't take
it under any circumstances
is it dangerous would you be worried
about a vaccine that was pushed through
so fast
and you know we have not talked about
this actually um
what i said to her was uh i'd far prefer
to take a vaccine that had
gone through all of the most rigorous
testing there is no time for that
i do not think that the way in which
that
this vaccine is has the possibility of
being less effective than it should
is likely to send it into the territory
of being dangerous
i i think it is likely to be less
efficacious
than it is supposed to be rather than
more dangerous than a more reliably
tested vaccine
what do you think about that well hey
this is a perfect segue into exactly
what we were going to
be talking about i would say one thing i
know for sure
is that we're damn well not going to be
allowed to talk about it the way we need
to talk about it in order to do
this properly we're going to be expected
to belittle the public and tell them a
fairy story about safety
in which their concerns are the result
of
wild-eyed fever dreams yadda yadda and
the adults have tested this thing and if
we say it's safe it's safe and all of
this is complete nonsense
now the vaccine will have gone through
testing hey i don't trust the testing
right i don't trust the testing because
i've seen what happens with drug safety
testing and
when somebody in this case me tries to
raise the alarm
about a glaring flaw in that system
the bell doesn't ring so what don't i
know about vaccine testing
who knows right i would also say that
there is a second
layer of informal testing that we know
didn't happen here which is if a vaccine
emerges
and it is given to people then time
passes and it is
not a good way of figuring out whether
something has happened but over time a
pattern
will emerge that something about the
vaccine we didn't know
has occurred people who've had it are
showing this symptom something like that
in this case there just simply hasn't
been enough time there hasn't been time
for the longitudinal studies longitude
referring exactly to time in this case
that we would normally
uh assume was necessary right and
what's more in this case and
i wasn't prepared to talk about this but
my understanding is that this vaccine as
a is of a very
interesting and i think highly unusual
type which i don't actually know
anything about it well
this is the pfizer vaccine we're talking
about yeah what i heard was
and in a high quality conversation
sophisticated people who wouldn't be
uh jawing off about this without having
done some work but
what i understood is that it is an mrna
vaccine
right which i believe means m stands for
messenger
right that doesn't give a lot of context
but well a particular type of rna
you've got dna which is made into a
template which is rna which is a
close relative of dna that mrna
is then sent to a basically a molecular
machine called a ribosome which turns it
into protein which is the active form
right and so a this is interesting
because
the thing that the coronavirus does is
basically hijack the cell
above the genome it doesn't integrate
into the genome this is a mistake i made
on one of our first live streams and
people correct it was a retro virus
yeah um and that's the mistake you're
talking about that was the mistake i
made
but it turns out that this coronaviruses
are interesting
in the sense that they uh travel above
the level of the genome they never
interact with it they hijack the
ribosomes and send the messages with it
they're epigenomic right well yes um
so in any case a vaccine that does the
same trick
um seems like it might actually be
quite safe on the other hand what we
don't know about the situation might be
larger than normal because this isn't a
variation
on a common theme as i understand it so
um you know no one does i mean i guess
the danger potentially is
what other mrna does it go after um
well there's all of the upstream danger
in other words
um you can trigger the immune system
to do things at the level of antigen you
can trigger the immune system
to to be forewarned about particles that
actually are hostile before it ever sees
them
right that would be a typical way so
like a typical mechanism for
a vaccine right you would take either
broken up pieces of dead virus
or live virus that isn't pathogenic
and you would put it in the system the
system would then do what it does
normally which is recognize that there's
something
unfamiliar here it must be an enemy and
it would learn to go after
it and then at the point that the real
pathogen shows up the system is already
primed
um so that's typical this is a very
different mechanism and so
um very you know uh but i had to i
haven't heard
all i've heard about the mechanism is
it's somehow engaging the mrna not what
it's
doing no no it is mrna if the vaccine is
mrna if i understand this correctly and
boy are we going to get some corrections
if i don't
yeah um but it is mrna and then what
like what what
well so the ribosomes transcribe
mrna when they run into it because
they're primed you know that's their
purpose and
the stuff comes out of the nucleus so
this mrna is going to
uh come into the system trigger
ribosomes and they are going to produce
proteins which do what um well
that's a good question do they so that's
that's the part that i don't get i don't
get
how plugging new mrna into your system
that then gets ribosomes to print new
protein deals with the coronavirus well
this protein has to have some particular
effect on the coronavirus over here so
we just
that's great that's the black box that's
there i have a connection
we should dig this up to the extent that
it is possible to do it but you know it
could be
that it is producing components of
antibodies
so antibodies for example are proteins
that have
sticky basically sticky pads on them and
those sticky pads
land on antigens that
they match and they can do all kinds of
things including gum up pathogens so
those pathogens can't access the surface
of cells and things
so i don't know it could be causing the
ribosomes to produce proteins that are
antibodies
as opposed to a more common mechanism of
vaccine which is
give give the body a little bit of
antigen itself the actual virus either
dead
or alive little pieces such that the
body is prompted to create those
antibodies well but that was going to be
my other
guess was that maybe it's producing
antigens that are
resident on viral particles and thereby
basically the vaccine in some sense is
being produced inside the cells
you know so if if a ribosome produces an
antigen found on a coronavirus and the
immune system then sees it
and recognizes it as foreign because
it's not in the library itself
then that could prime the system so
anyway
definitely we should dig to the extent
that it is possible i had no idea
i had heard nothing except pfizer's got
this vaccine that
they're hoping to get rich on all right
so now well so
i will say um that when this when this
acquaintance of ours asked me
i prefaced my um you know
investigating in terms of a manipulation
a biologist but not
knowledgeable with regard to these
particulars answered to her with
we will have our family vaccinated if i
unless there is something that i do not
understand
yet about um there being an increased
risk of
danger from this sort of vaccine uh then
a vaccine that might not be very
effective uh
is is one that that we should be taking
well uh i fall out quite differently
here and the problem is
to have the adult conversation is
potentially to trigger
a failure in the game theory realm that
people rightly fear
but the problem is the difference
between individual decisions and public
health
right so here's the thing we're not
allowed to say
my god wouldn't it be terrible if this
was true that the sweet spot
is for everybody else to take the
vaccine and you not therefore you don't
get the risk of the vaccine which has to
be
rated as substantial just based on the
unknowns based on the fact that there
will be no one on earth who has
had the vaccine a year ago and so we
don't know what it does a year out
right so if everybody took the vaccine
and you didn't you get the benefit of
their immunity
but nowhere close to everybody's gonna
take it right so then the game theory
i mean effectively this because you know
this this is one of the things
that um trump really failed at
so badly early in the coronavirus
pandemic which was
polarizing it polarizing the response to
it as opposed to saying
here's what we're going to do and you
know maybe we'll have to do something
else at some other point right
but turning us into star bellied
sneetches and sneetches without with
regard to masks
and now vaccines has
made it such that it's not possible to
assume that you would be the only person
in your community who wasn't vaccinated
right so there's no way right but
uh so there's a game look the problem is
that the game theory is relatively
straightforward right the more people
who are vaccinated the less
um you're being vaccinated actually
matters to your own
immunity assuming that the thing works
right the thing works the more people
who are vaccinated the less
you need to be vaccinated in order not
to get it because other people around
you will not have the pathogen in an
active form
if they've been vaccinated as people
register that
and they decide to play the game and
avoid the vaccine
then the number of people who've been
vaccinated goes down the risk of getting
the disease goes up and so you get into
this
very ugly equilibrium right which is
what the anti-vax
catastrophe shall we call it is about is
there is
a fear about vaccines
and people who are sophisticated about
understanding
the nature of the the game
recognize that those who opt out are in
effect
um exposing everybody else to greater
danger and
saving themselves on the risk of course
it's also true though that just as
early on the mass discussion was insane
right yes masks provide
no safety whatsoever this turns out to
have been a political decision
right and then masks are about you
protecting
other people right what then why
no yes that is also true but of course
the masks are going to protect
you as well so i see a similar sort of
analysis possible here with regard to
vaccines the anti-vaxxers can be like
nope
too dangerous i'm and if if they're sort
of savvy anti-vaxxers they're going to
argue well i'm going to get my benefit
from everyone else being vaccinated
well but there are two there are two
ways
of course that you can be safe
from the disease at least two one is not
be exposed
and you don't be exposed by being safe
and so and physical distancing
and wearing a mask when you're in the
presence of others inside and all of
this
and the vaccine is a second way that you
can be protected
that also comes with risks that we
cannot fully know
but that you cannot get any other way
right
so what i would say is in the case of
the masks the
the game is exactly the same but for one
thing
which is that the cost of the masks is
very
very low for most people and you and i
disagree on this
well so no it's very very low at the
level of let's say
safety now there are people for whom it
carries a safety
risk and there are you know i mean look
you're reducing
the effectiveness of a system that is
built to exhale into the world directly
you are reducing the effectiveness you
are causing
co2 at the very least to build up at a
higher rate so there it's not like
there's going to be zero effect but
you're talking entirely about an
anatomical and physiological risk
you're talking and so over in vaccine
space that is where the risk is right
entirely it's entirely about
in and of the body yeah and the risk
from masks for people who are otherwise
healthy
uh from mask wearing is is very low
exactly what you just said
yep um but there but we are as you know
this and this is our
our drum beat right that humans like a
few other species on the planet are so
much more than just our bodies and it is
all evolutionary
and the fact of walking around not being
able to actually
exchange meaning by looking at other
people's faces
and uh and you know and
having initial interactions immediately
made
painful and suspect because you're
walking on a trail in a park
and people leap out of the way because
they see you're not masked from 12 feet
away even though you're outside in
nature
uh there there is simply not enough
nuance uh around the discussion and you
know
it's i think it's very similar right and
um
in both cases you know pro mask pro
vaccine
but those aren't sufficient categories
right right pro mask
when it is under those conditions where
it is appropriate and most people don't
understand what those conditions are
and outside i am i am perfectly
comfortable but i don't like the looks
that i get
once i'm outside of the range of the
hvac at the supermarket immediately
taking my mask off
and having as i walk through the parking
lot with my groceries
in the cart having occasionally people
glare at me no
sorry i'm outside and i'm going to
breathe the air
okay so this is in some sense a perfect
prototype that you and i did not
settle on in advance but this is exactly
the conversation both sides are stupid
here
okay to the extent that we have a
dangerous virus
that we have misunderstood the hazard of
it as hazard of death which is lower
than we thought but that there is a much
greater hazard of
brain damage uh heart damage etc
right that um there is reason
to use a mask where a mask is effective
and there is reason to minimize mask use
right
not to signal with it when we're for
example outdoors where things are quite
safe still and
again that could change but it hasn't
yet as far as we know yep
um so in any case the problem is there
is nowhere for most people to stand
because the reasonable position is not
allowed
right and um sorry asterisk from
way back governor brown's order that's
about to send us
oregon into two weeks of whatever she's
calling it it's not the full shutdown
that we had in march april
because a lot of the retail businesses
are still allowed to be open just a
limited capacity um but among other
things that are closed is gardens
why the hell are they closing gardens
yeah unless unless they can make an
argument for it's the workers
except excuse me um you know someone
behind plexiglass taking tickets
is you know the only the only person who
needs to be there at the time
why are they closing gardens right
especially at a moment when we've got
the
you know where the windshield of the
continent and the firehose of the
pacific is on us
and if you could manage to get outside
and enjoy something you should
absolutely do it
yeah for reasons of mental health if
nothing else yes so
and so this this is my point about
actually
the you know the mask the mask analysis
is unnuanced
and the idea that well there's you know
what is it going to hurt you
no let's take a more expansive view of
of of harm actually let's move it beyond
the physical
and the physical health and into mental
health and social health
and i mean i think it was nicholas
christakis early in this who said
maybe it wasn't him he certainly started
to say it but
you know no we shouldn't be social
distancing we should be physical
distancing
and it's really hard to do the one
without the other
um but it's even harder when you can't
see people's faces
right so the problem is we could
outline we could sketch the
uh there's got to be a better word than
smart but the smart
position in which you pay as little cost
as you have to for masks but you get the
benefit right
you want the sweet spot of how much mask
wearing to do and where is it
and how can you minimize your wearing of
masks and still get
98 percent of the value of them right
we can do that but the problem is the
game
theory causes a
social enforcement of a lie about
the utility and the same thing happens
in vaccine space so there are people who
will hear the discussion that we just
had
as somehow heresy because
it acknowledges the hazard of vaccines
and acknowledges that in this case
there's a special hazard that just comes
from the fact that it hasn't been out
very long
right and so there has to be a way
for us to have a proper conversation and
one thing i would say is
again in the vaccine case both sides are
stupid
right we have a safety system that can't
possibly work because of the perverse
incentives surrounding the economics of
vaccine production
right they're more dangerous than they
need to be because there's a perverse
incentive
surrounding the hazard right
that means that we are in a v we're in a
thoroughly compromised position
when it comes to the game theory and
saying to people you know what
they're not totally safe right we've
made them as safe as they can be
right we here's here's how you know that
they're as safe as they can be without
being perfectly safe and you need to
take your share of the risk along with
the rest of us
so that we can get the collective
benefit of us being immune and
frankly driving pathogens out of
existence or to very low levels
that comes from wide compliance with
these things but unfortunately
those of us who you know i think
vaccines are one of the
most powerful inventions humanity has
ever come up with but i cannot just be
a uh a booster for vec that's a terrible
term
vaccine booster i cannot be a
cheerleader for vaccines given the
economic model and the way it
compromises
safety i have to be in this camp where
you know
i'm constantly getting beaten up because
uh people want me to tell the public
these things are safe and you're you
know you're a conspiracy theorist for
believing they might not be well you and
i agree
about some of the basically the
top uh
developmental discoveries of western
medicine
being vaccines antibiotics and then also
several surgical techniques
and that a whole lot of the rest of what
is going on
has has been done better in a lot of
cases by other
other traditions actually um but in part
by interfering less with physiology that
we don't understand exactly or by
on by coming at it just from a different
perspective and therefore being able to
see like with anamorphic art
something that you could not see from
the uh cut it or pilot
attitude which is increasingly what the
western medicine approach is
but you know to say that antibiotics are
one of the great
great discoveries creations of humankind
does not suggest that they haven't been
wildly overprescribed
aren't making us all sick aren't making
our cattle sick and therefore the people
that eat those cattle sick
and the people who drink the milk and
like all of these things
are also true so it does to say that
it's one of the great inventions of
humankind
does not mean that you think it's all
good all the time
so i will also say that um i think
you've you've waited into this a little
bit more than i have so you've gotten
more pushback than i have
um but you know the idea that you are
some sort of a
vaccine denier or an anti-vaccine our
family is probably far more vaccinated
than just about anyone watching because
of where we've traveled
right and um when our kids were very
young i started pushing for us to
take them places and you i think
correctly said nope not yet
um because because
the drugs that we need to give them to
keep them safe to travel in some of
these places
are not safe for them when they're that
young yeah the longer you wait through
development
the less harm given an amount of harm
done by a drug or a vaccine the later it
comes in development the less damaging
it is
exactly and so um at the point that we
did
start traveling to really far-flung
places like like the amazon with them
which would have been when they were
what like 11 and 9 maybe
something like that um we were able to
give them
not with perfect safety but things like
the yellow fever vaccine which is
actually
like required by law but also we would
have done had had we gone there because
it has been around for a long time
yellow fever is one of these mosquito
vector diseases that is
deadly that has wiped out whole
populations
uh and furthermore in that case i also
feel it is our responsibility not just
to
keep us safe but to go into a place
where you are traveling into a place
where other people don't travel between
if there's any chance that you could
bring a disease in that is that's not an
acceptable risk to
to bring to the people who already live
there however
we neither of us have ever gotten the
cholera vaccine because the cholera
vaccine
while it's also been around for a while
is understood not to have its
i don't remember the numbers um
something like 30 to 40 efficacy
and it's not particularly dangerous but
all vaccines bring with them some risk
and the fact is that the cure for
cholera largely especially for
um you know comparatively wealthy people
north americanos
is um to have access to clean water
which
we would always be able to have access
to and so we make these decisions one by
one
right and you know i have been wanting a
malaria vaccine since we began traveling
to latin america decades ago at this
point
but that doesn't mean that as soon as
one shows up it's right away the moment
to
to take it because i've also gone
through what four different kinds of
malaria prophylaxis one of which
is completely horrifying and i hope
never to be on something like that again
so
you know you you have to be able to look
at the options before you and say
who who do i trust who knows more about
this than i do and what are they saying
and also how is it that i can rely on my
own knowledge and make decisions for
myself
that said public health is a different
kind of analysis which is where you
started here
right and so i think the the bottom line
well there's two bottom lines
one when it comes to things like
medicine
uh there's a a an analog to the
principle
that the government that governs best
governs least which does not mean
actually least it means least necessary
to do the job
that the medicine that functions best
functions least that our tendency to
want to interfere in a system
always comes with side effects and to
the extent that there are interventions
that reduce
the uh intensity of the intervention
they tend to be
far better sure but once if you're
looking for a vaccine you're already in
arms race
right so a vaccine is inherently sort of
a combative property
that is going to do some some some war
somewhere on some part of hopefully most
of the pathogen you're trying to combat
but also presumably your body
right and you know what is the effect of
you know if one vaccine is great
is there or do we really imagine there's
no cost to
just vaccinating you to everything that
we can uh
possibly create a vaccine for or is
there some cumulative cost
i don't think we know the answer to
these questions
so anyway one of the one of the lessons
here is about
medicine and a non-interventionist bent
just as you want a light hand in
government a light hand in medicine
saves you from all of the things you
didn't know about the system you were
interfering with
um the other one has to do with the game
theory and frankly my
i'm sick and tired of being shouted at
by people
who don't want me to say the truth
because they are afraid it will cause
people to tune into the game theory and
not participate in something like
vaccines
my point is now there's actually no way
around
the adult discussion here which involves
owning up to the fact that the system
isn't nearly as safe as it might be
and that basically there are two sides
to this contract
if we're going to get if we're going to
belittle people and maybe require them
to take vaccines
we have an absolute obligation to make
these things as safe as possible first
right there's no two ways about that and
so and to speak
with some nuance and to allow people the
possibility
of actually understanding what is going
on because when you make broadcast
claims like
masks do not help or vaccines are a
hundred percent
safe you of course increase the distress
that people have and increase the
non-compliance that people have with
with these rules
because some of them are clearly
political and lies
and um you know we really really hope
uh that that you know this or many
multiple vaccines that get produced
are not are not built on lives but
on what basis are we supposed to trust a
political pronouncement
about this at this point right the whole
landscape of discussion
discussion that masquerades as
analytical has been politicized to the
point that we are now
unable to talk about even the basics of
how we are to interact with each other
or how we are to protect ourselves from
threats that we all face yeah and you
know
whatever process it is that allowed that
to happen
has put us in very serious jeopardy and
we have to counteract it
and this um this actually we've already
been a number of the places that we were
we were hoping to go we wanted to talk
about whether or not there are questions
that should not be asked
and topics that should not be approached
and i was reminded that we
when we were in grad school we had a
professor um who
you know actually and this is somewhat
relevant was of a somewhat marxist bent
um who told us uh when we were in the
field with him at some point that there
were questions that should not be asked
for fear that the answers would be ugly
or not good for society
and um you know we were in grad school
in biology and he was a biology
professor and i thought
that seems like an extraordinarily
anti-scientific
approach and i'm frankly shocked that a
scientist
would advise other you know burgeoning
scientists
that they need to stay away from certain
questions because
because the truth might imprison you is
effectively what the message is right
the truth will not set you free in his
worldview the truth might imprison you
and therefore
we need to protect everyone from it so
you know it's
it's hard to know whether or not there
is actually some place where that
principle
that he was espousing is correct
i'm not certain that there isn't but
what i am certain of
is that just as with uh the case of
you know free speech and things along
these lines we have an
absolute obligation to leave everything
on the table until there is a very
compelling reason that something can't
be on the table because you will rule
out
all kinds of important stuff the natural
process of progress
requires us to be able to discuss all
sorts of things and throw them out
and um well and i will say that um
asking the questions
is different from throwing technology at
it and trying to develop
new things right like they're right oh
yeah we're in a very different territory
when we're for instance talking about
whether or not cloning humans might be a
good idea
as opposed to starting down a path to
cloning without having actually
really thought through you know had all
those conversations
a lot of times with a lot of different
people right asking a question
is not the same thing as engaging in
work that modifies things and the number
of places you know
should you work on ice 9 if you uh
discover a way that you might create
such a thing
you know this is fun vonnegut reference
yeah vonnegut reference to if i recall
correctly a
a molecule that causes um
liquid water to turn solid upon contact
for which book
um you know or yeah
geez should you should you get involved
in gain of function research
on coronaviruses that enhances the
uh infectiousness and uh lethality of
these things to study the
you know the pathology and epidemiology
of these diseases that's
you know the entire population of the
world should not get to be in on those
conversations
but there should be a lot of
conversations involving not just the
researchers who stand to gain
but including for instance bioethicists
and and such well i want to
back you off that a little bit i think i
know what you mean right the entire
world doesn't get to sit at the table
and discuss the reasonableness of this
but we need to have a body that is free
from corruption that discusses whether
or not the benefit is worth
the unknown risk of engaging in these
kinds
representative democracy at in more
domains than it currently is
right so all right um
and um you know with regard we were with
regard to
topics that should not be approached and
questions that should not be asked
um you were dragged i don't there's a
lot of places here that we want to go
still but
you were dragged for uh presumably
giving fuel to trump's fire
uh by talking about the possibility of
election fraud which we talked about a
little bit last week too and actually
last week
um you you had seen nothing to suggest
that anything was going on and i had
this sense of like
i'm just not i don't know it just this
doesn't feel right to me
and i don't really know where where you
land at this point and regardless of
what either of us think it doesn't
change what's true
yeah well so i saw
a mathematical analysis that i found uh
difficult to falsify that suggested
anomalies that were certainly you know
so i think i did a pretty good job i
pointed to this
analysis and i said i don't spot the
analytical flaw here i ran it by
uh four mathematically sophisticated
people and i said do you see anything
here that i don't see i should point out
because people will assume eric was one
of them he wasn't
just to preserve his independence but
anyway uh i ran it by people nobody
spotted a flaw and so i released it
carefully i said i don't spot a flaw if
there is one i'll be glad to see it
but until i know that there's a flaw um
i
i think this is worth looking at
somebody
who was not the least bit decent about
it
um did an analysis that i found
difficult to understand but when i
finally did understand it did
falsify the evidence that seemed to be
contained in the anomalies in the first
analysis
and so i put that out i appended it to
each of the places that i had
talked about this analysis that raised
the question
and i said yep this does appear to
account for it on the basis of a
rounding error so it's not evidence um
but the blowback from doing this was
uh spectacular and the number of people
who considered it some kind of heresy or
sin or something
was amazing and you know you're not
allowed to ask those questions
yeah it's again stay in your lane it's
not even
it's not even your lane it is yeah and
this stay away
from analysis this is not a place for
analysis and the more i think
about it so ah there is there are some
there are some places that whatever your
lane is you're not allowed to go
irrespective of what the truth is don't
you dare raise those questions in public
and my feeling is who the hell are you
to decide this and
if you're going to decide such things
you have an absolute obligation even
though i will oppose you for deciding
them you have an absolute obligation to
be even-handed about them
right how much crap did we get dragged
through
over russiagate and supposed collusion
between the trump administration
and uh the russian government right
which came to nothing right this was
apparently
perfectly reasonable to be discussed on
the front page of the new york times
right but if it's the other side you
can't even ask the question
even though there are literally
trillions of dollars at stake in an
american presidential
election right that is a huge amount of
incentive
for bad behavior what's more in this
case the presidential election on both
sides
the candidate was understood by people
on the other side to be an existential
threat
right that's another whole layer of
incentives and by a small number of us
they both were
right exactly so at some level
you're just dumb not to consider the
possibility of collusion in an american
presidential election which doesn't mean
that you have evidence for it
i would further point out to complicate
things all american presidential
elections are now stolen
mostly it's legal but the point is we've
all just gotten so
used to the idea that these massive
corrupting influences
have some right to play a role in our
process
and that that directly affects who we
end up electing
yes it happens subtly because it's very
often in the primaries
that the skull buggery happens and then
maybe we get to vote like normal
people members of a democracy in the
general election but come on there is so
much
going on in these elections that has
nothing to do with the consent of the
governed
that asking whether or it has extended
into a new realm is
its our obligation frankly yeah i would
i would push back a little bit on
identifying the things that
you just identified as evidence of
stolen
elections you know we have we have
talked before i think on
air about the role that uh social media
and indeed the mainstream media have on
affecting what people
see and what people think and whether or
not that is affected
effectively a kind of election tampering
and might we therefore call
such elections that are downstream of
that stolen in some regard
uh maybe but i think we need to be
i think we need to be careful using the
strongest words
uh when when this is what we're talking
about
i accept that i accept that but um i
will say
you know a lot has happened as a result
of the attempts to unearth this process
even just the recognition and i was
looking
uh at the wikipedia entry on wikileaks
actually
and reminded that um you know what
spilled out of
the dnc in 2016
revealed effectively that the dnc
had systematically uh
sabotaged opposed used all kinds of
mechanisms to oppose bernie sanders
getting the nomination and they
succeeded in preventing it from
happening and you know okay
so i think the point is
when you say influence peddling and
people say well what do you mean what
you know well there's influence peddling
it's obvious that people
this is a pay-for-play system the fact
that it's not illegal doesn't mean it's
not influence peddling
the fact that the you know what the dnc
argued in court about the sabotage of
bernie sanders was not that it didn't
happen but that they had the right to
was their party
right so if that's the world we're
living in let's just at least be honest
about the fact that that's the world
we're living no exactly and i think
i don't know what they actually said so
attributing um
to them the words that you just said
they said isn't quite fair but they do
feel like it's their party not our party
well not his party not not well put that
aside
their party not our party right like
it's it's not it's not actually about
all of the people who are registered as
whatever party it is um it is it is
about the people in power who are making
policy for the rest of us and this
actually you know this this this brings
up
a question of ideology and what makes a
person an ideologue which i thought i
think we want to go to a little bit here
um but let's see um
i think we've basically talked about
well let's spend a little bit more time
first on this
this really nasty little put down that
happens which is stay in your lane
and how you know you and i both have
been saying for i think decades at this
point
no will not you've defined the lane even
if it's a real line in the first place
uh there's a good chance that um i have
insight into a whole bunch of these
other lanes and even if i don't i'm
still allowed to go there
and you know one of the things that is
true as evolutionary biologists is that
aside from rocks and quarks and a few
other abiotic things
it's kind of all our lane anyway so that
is that is
one thing that i'm going to claim here
but it's just regardless of who
who you are receiving the advice that
you need to stay on your
in your lane it's a cheap shot um it
works as censorship it's a tool
to to silence you it works to silo
people
and thus further make the problem of
there's going to have to be more and
more policing of staying in the lane
it establishes the role of authorities
to dictate from on high to the plebes
who are supposed to just receive it and
accept it whatever it is maybe it's the
dnc maybe it's the rnc maybe it's the
religious authorities whoever it is
um and i think most interestingly and
what we can what we can add most
uniquely here is that it misses
one of the core tensions and brilliances
of what it is to be human
which is that we are simultaneously
generalists and specialists
right and so this is this is something
you've been talking about for many many
years and
and to some degree i have as well and
it's one of the
the central themes of of the book that
we are writing
um which is that humans are the most
generalist species on earth
and yet individually many of us
are such specialists that we far
outstrip any individual in any given
in any other species in terms of our
ability to do a particular thing
so how is it that we can be both most
generalist and most specialist
well it's it's that way by being
specialist at the individual level and
generalist at the population level
which therefore reminds us that we
actually need to be
with one another we we all can
um aspire to be more generalists within
ourselves individually but also to be
with other human beings with whom we
connect
and therefore increase our command our
wealth
of understanding and wisdom in the world
yes and
uh not to put too fine a point on it the
fraction of human well-being that is
ultimately traceable to somebody not
staying in their lane is
so large that anybody who wants to
impose this rule now whatever a lane may
be that you should stay in it
is obviously foregoing a huge amount of
progress that might occur going forward
and so
screw up yeah it's probably not fair but
you know we could
we could pretty quickly start naming
people throughout history who didn't
stay in their lane and leonardo da vinci
seems to come right to the top
you know any anyone who's ever gone to a
uh
uh art installation museum installation
that just just simply portrays some tiny
fraction of what that man did it's
extraordinary
and the fact is um you know just to take
two things that are often described as
sort of polar opposites at least within
academia art and science
need one another and they thrive for one
another and they build on one another
and so many of the
best scientists have had some
kind of artistic passion
or you know or craft passion or building
passion
some something that gave them a totally
different road in a totally different
lens
angle whatever it is in to how it is
that they observe the world
yeah i'm imagining actually a uh
a wonderful graphic you know
uh somehow my lane right and you can
imagine a lane
like going fractal in some sort of
psychedelic explosion of whatever of
chaos
yeah and you know i don't i don't invoke
idw
hardly ever but not staying in your lane
yeah
that's what it's about right it's
pursuing truth and ideas wherever they
lead
wherever they lead that's what it's
supposed to be about
and um so you know super interesting
whenever it happens
but especially now in light of the ever
more siloing contentious
nasty conversations that people seem to
be willing to have
especially online but i suspect in in
person too you know safely behind their
masks
no let us let us remember that we are
all human
and that there will be something to
disagree with
in the opinions and thoughts of every
single other human on the planet and
for almost everyone you can probably
find some things to just
to agree with as well so i wanted to add
a final thing that i've been thinking
this week watching
people react to various people leaving
their lanes including me
and all of that and there's a i think
there's just a basic
failure in people's model of how to
think carefully
and you know a lot of us have understood
now that there is no
reliable neutral source on a lot of
things and many people have
talked about their methods for dealing
with that involving having two sources
open
and moving between them in order that
they can correct for the distortions on
both sides
but there's also a human analog to this
right
i would say we are now watching a
a social dynamic unfold where many
people
are understood to be losing their minds
and the accusation that an individual
person has finally lost their mind is
now
commonplace now i don't want to claim
that this is all nonsense i see people
out there that i believe
are losing their minds and in fact greg
lukianov
had a thread today on twitter in which
he took a particular
account a i think the person's identity
is known but the account is anonymous
the pope hat account
he took them to task for basically
uh belittling concerns about
cancellation and being driven out of a
newspaper or
university or whatever um and so
by the most recent move of maddie
iglesias from vox
and earlier barry weiss and andrew
sullivan and matt taibbi
and glenn greenwald greenwald yeah right
um and so
anyway there's a question i would just
say look if i
if i follow somebody right if i'm paying
attention to their work
and then they suddenly say something
that i know to be wrong
right i know they've just said something
that doesn't make any goddamn sense my
first thought is not up
they finally lost their mind my first
thought is
i wonder if there's something i don't
see in that place
what don't i understand as opposed to
how dare you sir right how dare you
exactly and i
i don't i don't understand when it comes
at me and it's like oh
you know yeah i used to respect
weinstein but he's lost it now
i feel like jesus if i built up
credibility with you
and then i say something that you find
bizarre just take
a minute and think about whether or not
i see something you don't and it may be
that i don't
but um yeah go ahead well uh so
you do this you i a number of people do
this and it
you reveal in so doing that you're not
controllable right
um and some people are going to show up
to tell you that they're disappointed in
you
and they that they used to have respect
for you but now they don't or
they you know something must have
happened are you feeling quite okay
right
and it's quite possible and it certainly
has happened and it will happen again
that you or i whoever it is
has aired right of course but it's also
quite possible
and quite common you are finding this
week
for the person lobbing this critique to
have slotted you into a category
right um democrat environmentalist
fascist you know whatever the category
is
which is actually more constraining than
clarifying even if
it's if it's a category like democrat or
environmentalist one which you might
own yourself or if it's one like fascist
one that is just lobbed at you and
people are just hoping some of it'll
stick but
regardless it's a categorization
and the idea that people are
carrying around these categories like
they're not engaging
you or me or whatever and this is far
easier on social media than it would be
in real life
as oh well that's this guy and he's got
these eight labels in my head wait he
just said something that
tick tick tick tick tick doesn't match
any of those labels
therefore he's lost it like no
maybe it's a literally a category error
like maybe your category is flawed
or maybe fitting a category is itself
a sign of an ideologue like this is what
ideologues are it's
it's people who you know and and this is
in service of
you know the easiest examples are
religions and political parties right
like
we have a slate of beliefs or a slate of
planks
that create a whole wealth of identity
for you
and if you just accept it if you just
accept everything here
you will find it easier to move your
through your life because you can find
the people with with whom you won't have
to be in contentious arguments
and you will find a community maybe
you'll find a
a partner you'll find friends it's all
very easy
and for those of us who for you know
there are a number of ways that you can
arrive at going actually
i'm gonna it's gonna take longer but i'm
gonna try to do the first principles
thing as much as possible and actually
not just accept that because i'm a
democrat i'm therefore
um interested in all gun regulation ever
for instance just just to pick an easy
one
um it confounds people and
they respond by saying how how dare you
sir
you must have really lost it like
actually i might be wrong
i might be wrong but what i'm doing is
trying to figure out what i believe
given what the evidence is in front of
me
i am not trying to conform to a category
i am not trying to conform to the thing
that you already had in your head about
me
that's not my job and it shouldn't be
what you're trying to do so with me
in some sense they are using a heuristic
how to spot an insane person
right and that's their problem if you're
using first principles yes and it causes
you to fall out somewhere different
than whatever their group is doing and
they're using a heuristic to quickly
spot crazy people
right that's not on you right right and
in fact
you know there are a couple of good
examples of this i i want to be careful
here because i haven't
followed what madrid is up to so closely
but a lot of people are worried about
majid and i think because he appears to
have come out
in favor of trump although he's not an
american but you know
online but on the other hand if you
follow him i don't i don't know i mean
we we had a wonderful dinner with him a
while ago but i
i don't know anything about the modern
controversy well i think it comes down
to the fact that there are lots of
cocktail parties in which anybody who
uh has so much has flirted with the
possibility
that either the blue side was so
horrible or that the red side wasn't
that bad is obviously a nut
and um the problem you know in majjid's
case you asked the question all right
i respect majid i know him right he's
saying something
this is yeah
could a guy that smart and that tuned in
get to this position well it's actually
not that hard the guy was recently
on hunger strike uh to get the british
parliament to debate the question of the
uyghurs in china
right so if you're munching dude feels
strongly about real stuff
and he thinks it through and what kind
of real stuff the kind of stuff we tell
ourselves that we would all do the right
thing in the case right we've got
you know effective concentration camps
we have organ harvesting
really appalling stuff right he's
committed enough
to dealing with this that he goes on
hunger strike and so
if you believe as many people do in fact
i think there's a very strong argument
to be made for it
that trump is better on china than uh
democratic administrations have been
that they've been a bit blind to the
hazard of china
then okay you can see how majid would
end up there or yeah
oh yeah actually i hadn't occurred to me
that it's internally consistent with his
last big public thing yep
i don't know whether that's what
happened but i do know that it's not
hard to figure out how a reasonable
how without losing his mind majid could
find himself there
right um likewise james lindsey right
james lindsey has taken a ton of flak
from people
over his support for trump but if you
listen to him his point is look i hate
this
but i'm concerned about the danger of
wokeness toppling institutions that
we're dependent on
so if you believe as he does it's not
hard to see how you would end up there
and
all i would say is look high quality
thinking involves not using some
heuristic and deciding people are
crazy because they happen to have
reached a different conclusion that you
regard as crazy
you have to figure out whether there's
some first principles way they might
have gotten there
and you know do you know more about uh
the about chinese abuse of the uyghurs
and the effect of different
administrations
uh in the u.s on uh the power of
china in this case well if you if you
don't know more than majid then you know
at least you have to give him the
benefit of the doubt that he has arrived
at a reasonable conclusion given his
priors
that's right and um it seems in fact to
be
consistent right uh what what he what he
is doing given the argument that you
just laid out
and i know you you know i was blissfully
mostly not
online this week um but i know you to be
consistent and you know that doesn't
mean that you don't
see new evidence and change your mind
but you are consistent in your
application
of of you know care and rigor in
assessing what's coming in and you
god you're more than i think anyone else
i know just constantly going back
through
and testing the assumptions that the
decision tree is based on that the
assumption that the
you know the idea tree is based on um
you know i the little bit of being
online this week that that i
had involved in part running into this
crazy um this crazy pronouncement from
the uk government
that basically i'm not going to pull it
up here but
all you have to do is read the
three-step pronouncement and you
basically arrive at
uh sex is based on chromosomes and
hormones like
no actually it's gametes but forget that
sex is based on chromosomes and hormones
and oh by the way sex is assigned at
birth
uh it doesn't take very much logic to
conclude that the government of the
united kingdom thinks that chromosomes
and hormones
are assigned at birth and um you know
this
this is um you know
no harm intended to or meant ever to
actual trans people but this is trans
rights activism this is the loony
horrifying dangerous fringe of trans
rights activists who are taking over the
entire conversation
um that has now gotten to the uk
government and so many other places
and you know i tweeted a few things
about this and
um from from various angles but um in
part you know i feel totally okay
mocking a government i don't i don't
tend to want to mock an individual
unless they
unless they push me repeatedly in a
particularly stupid way
but um i saw a little bit of
conversation
suggesting that i and actually i think
you were named too
in the discussion of this um that we
were on this topic
meaning as i understand it basically um
the biology of sex
were ideologues and i thought
well i thought of that princess bride um
quote
you know i don't i don't think you know
what that term means right
um but i also thought okay my god like
how do you even get there
how do you even get from like not only
am i is firmly in my lane
you know evolution of sex is like what
i've been doing for
for for decades now um but the
consistency here
in my position is what has now gotten me
labeled an ideologue so i just went
through like okay what
what can consistency in an argument
indicate right like let's just let's
just walk through it
so consistency in opinion over time
can mean that you've actually you
originally investigated it from
first principles as much as possible
hopefully and you continue to
investigate
investigate the question and you
continue to
feel that your original position was
correct that's one
way that you can end up consistent in an
argument right
um it might be that you did originally
investigate it but then you sort of
went like set and forget i'm not going
to continue to think about that i know
what i once thought i must still think
that
in which case your consistency over time
actually holds no information
as to what you really think that doesn't
make you an ideologue inherently but it
does mean that you should feel less and
less certain of your stated opinion
the longer it's been since you've gone
back to it and reconsidered what new
evidence there might be
so that's a second reason the second way
that you can
reveal consistency and what it can mean
and then a third one
i would say is that you never thought it
through for yourself in the first place
right you simply accepted the
conclusions of for instance oh a
political party or religion or whatever
and in that case that provides no
evidence at all
as to whether or not you believe the
thing and guess what in that case
there's a good chance
you're an ideologue but that's one of
three categories
of how it is that you might end up
consistent on a point and always
defaulting or you know when people
default to well
boy you keep banging this strum this is
a point that you've made over and over
again you must be an ideologue
that's really impoverished thinking
that's like really bad logic
it's the same damn thing it's somebody
applying their heuristic
you know if you've got three routes to
consistency
and your heuristic is in general when
people are this consistent it's because
they've there's an ideology driving them
and then it's your heuristic that's the
fault not the person who's being
consistent
right right which doesn't mean the
heuristic doesn't work a lot of the time
it really does that's why you have it
but
um but anyway they're i think
if there's a like a nugget here to be
derived
it's okay if you've learned that the way
you're gonna figure out
the way you're gonna correct for the
bias in media is you're gonna have two
opposing bits of media
facing each other and use each to
correct for the other
there's another way to do it that
involves people right if you
follow somebody right i would argue that
one of the ways to recognize somebody
who is not an ideologue
right is a that their belief structure
does not match anybody's slate
right they are dining a la carte because
they are arriving at conclusions
independently based on first principles
which will result in an eclectic
mix of conclusions the other thing is
how well do they reverse course when
they are revealed to be wrong
right right if somebody is not good at
that that's a red flag if somebody is
good at that
that suggests well actually you can
afford to put your weight on the ice so
you know just as you have the two
sources you might go to to correct
you might have a small slate of people
that you actually trust
enough that when they come to a
conclusion that seems batshit crazy from
where you're coming from
it doesn't cause you to declare them
batshit crazy but it makes you think
well
what do they see that i don't right
right that's exactly right
yeah yeah that's that's terrific yeah
uh so well
there's many more places we could go uh
or we could
stop here well i have one thing i want
to talk about because
i have a sense that it's timely and it
you know i don't know how long
it lasts okay next week then we'll talk
about whether or not
women were big game hunters in
pre-columbian americas how big were that
no
terrible joke um uh
so what i wanted to talk about is um
this thing
clubhouse which you have i think you are
technically on it but you haven't been
there
yeah yeah i have it on my phone i've
been invited but i've never
never visited yeah so i have to define
what it is yeah
clubhouse is a new social media
platform that has emerged i don't know
how old it is and frankly i don't know
how many people are on it it still seems
quite small
on the inside which could be an optical
illusion or not but
anyway it's created a lot of buzz in
silicon valley
there are lots of silicon valley types
on it
and just the basics of it um actually
zach did i send you a screenshot of it
yeah okay so this is like a room inside
of clubhouse
um this is from this morning and it
involves so the key thing to this social
media platform is there's effectively no
text other than your profile and your
name everything is done
uh by speaking and it's not recorded so
it's totally in the moment
it is totally in the moment um you know
there's always a danger that somebody
will record it but no it's like you
can't go
and sort of scroll through listen to
past conversations right so it's
ephemeral by nature
it is conversational it's audio snapchat
yeah and it mixes people in a way that
i'm finding
very unusual for the moment so there
are some ideological lines inside of
clubhouse
but at least until yesterday you saw all
of the public rooms that were available
they have titles which may or may not be
all that indicative of what's going on
in there and you saw some indication of
who was in the room and you could just
drop in and listen um so the idea is
that you can go into any room you want
but you have to be invited to have a
voice in that room
yes okay that's correct um and so the
person who starts it and whoever they
designate as moderators
can invite you on stage or if you want
to come on stage and you haven't been
invited you can raise your hand and they
can
bring you up but you cannot put yourself
in you can't walk in and just start
yelling right
um so anyway the
i think there are a couple things that
are going on here one so far
i don't think the thing has a business
model it's still in the generating buzz
phase right which is a very interesting
phase because it doesn't have the
constraints that come along with the
economics of the model so it's still
lively and nobody knows what it is and
we're all learning the rules and
that sort of thing so it's more dynamic
than it might otherwise
um be but uh
so there's there's also a lot at stake
and people
um i don't know how people you can
invite two people if you're in
i think um and then people who were
there at the founding presumably invited
a lot of people in
but people don't necessarily know who
everybody is it's not necessarily clear
from profile so there is a lot of
mixing going on in this app you know
across
huge you know orders of magnitude in
terms of economic status
education is widely variable
there's a very strong black contingent
in clubhouse
some of that is you know
consequential in the sense that there
are rooms that are explicitly labeled
as black and they often have a very
different culture than other parts of
clubhouse
but anyway it's
i think it is going to ultimately
collapse into
another version of all the things that
we already have
because in some sense it's going to face
the same selective pressure
where the desire to you know in
competition with other social media
sites
it's going to have to feed people
that which will keep them coming back
spending time
and that is going to involve i believe
unless they are very very careful it is
going to involve
reinforcing people's existing beliefs in
other words we haven't yet
seen filter bubbles emerge in a powerful
way there
but as soon as the economics kick in
it's going to be there with a vengeance
and i think i think you have not yet
said that you saw
what you think is the first pivot point
in this yesterday
yes the first pivot point well i don't
know because i came in at some moment i
don't even know how long it had been
going
but the first pivot point that i saw and
one that is very clearly a step in this
direction
is that the ability to see all of the
public rooms disappeared
yesterday the update of the app caused
it so that you would only see rooms i
think with people that you
follow so and it's not you can't
change that setting you can't then also
go scroll through all the public ones so
it's not it can't
really be argued as a look this doesn't
scale
we have to be able to show people the
top 30 or whatever
it's actually now completely blocked you
from even seeing a bunch of what's going
on you don't even know what you're
missing
right and so i advocated yesterday
in a room where this was being discussed
hey we actually need the ability to
override whatever's going on because for
some of us
it's not even that you know if you
follow a wide range of people then it
broadens the scope of things that you
see
we actually need to find the room that
is most opposite to the one we would be
expected to be in in order to
tune into a conversation we need to know
about that we can't find yeah no and get
and given that
um given that you can't given that you
have to be invited to speak
um it you don't no one is at risk of
having their conversation destroyed
right yeah i i think now i know there's
there's a separate question never having
been on this
um you know for me privacy always rises
pretty high
in the rankings and you know i would if
if i were going to end up using this i'd
probably want to be able to have a
private room
where i invited eight people or whatever
right um although in that case
how is it different from a phone call
right right um
but the you know the option for privacy
is quite different
from not being able to see um
to to see and choose to go into all of
these rooms and you know i would say
that even if there were private rooms
um i would want the option to see or
that's that's something
that's happening i can't see what's
behind that door but all these other
doors that i never would have been shown
given the new filter on it um yeah most
of them
i don't want to go to but um i want to
know they're there and i'd like to pop
in and see
sometimes to listen absolutely so i want
to point to
two things one there is um
on you know people talk frequently about
black twitter i feel like there's
clearly a black clubhouse but i've never
heard the term used
right but it's there and you'll find
rooms with you know
sometimes 100 people in which pretty
much everybody's black
and these rooms um
you know there's an awful lot of black
vernacular
spoken and there's a lot of you know
there are rooms in which the n word is
every fifth word
right people are referring to other
people with this term it's very jarring
but it's also very
interesting to be able to hear such a
conversation right
um so that's one thing that's going on
but what i saw
happen yesterday and what i participated
in yesterday
to me was uh
quite singular so
there was a room yesterday that somebody
started on the question of
socialism communism and capitalism that
was the title of the room and it was
clear
the purpose of the room was to discuss
the merits of these things
and so i went in i wanted to hear what
this discussion was first i wanted to
know if they were going to define these
terms because
that's a can of worms in and of itself
but anyway
i went into the room and you know they
were having a discussion
you know something you might expect you
know that you could hear on a college
campus
for example and i went on stage
and i of course you did i couldn't
resist
and i started um pushing a little bit
you know to see if i could get the
conversation to
shift and people met me where i was
which was cool right
now this was a very diverse room i don't
know why actually but
it had diversity it was diverse in every
way
right so uh their
sex sexual orientation race
um uh religion
so you know there were on stage there
was a native american
there was a uh a muslim
there were many blacks several whites
male and female
gay and straight go ahead uh i
i just want to asterisk object to the
idea of
sex being a category that is used in
diversity
because it's binary and i'm not sure
that a binary category
is um qualifies as diverse i feel like
you have to have a category that has
more than
more than two two states um okay
i accept i'm not you're not the guy who
did that i'm just
whenever i hear that i think i'm not
sure that's diversity
anyway in any case this room went on for
four hours right very popular big room
right and people were very eager to
speak it had a kind of a hybrid culture
right it wasn't the free-for-all that
some find you sometimes find in some of
these rooms and it wasn't there's a
so there's a free-for-all culture where
people have their they're not on mute
and they just
talk over each other like they're
sitting at a a dinner table
right and then there's another culture
which is sort of like the silicon valley
uh academic culture in which everybody's
on mute and one person
talks and then they go you know they
might talk for three minutes and then
they
hit mute and then the next person jumps
in and all of this this was sort of a
hybrid which was interesting
but it emerges that there are some blm
guys
in this room room was started by a
a black guy who was um
moderating uh
he would he had power to moderate and he
moderated very well in other words he
kept
um the conversation dynamic
so anyway what i heard for the first
time in a long time
was a conversation that moved in the
direction of
race and power and politics and
economics but did not derail over all of
the things that caused such
conversations to fall apart
in modern circumstances so what i
typically see
is either a conversation has many
perspectives and it derails over
accusations of who's defective in what
way
or it's a bunch of people who have a
similar
perspective and it doesn't derail but
it's not all that generative because
there's
wide agreement over the conclusion right
yeah this was not that
and i think everybody felt about it that
it was
extremely positive and i guess my
concern is that whatever is
possible there now is going to fall
apart as a result of the economics of
the situation
i will say i tuned in this morning there
was another room
on code switching right a mixed room
black and white and a discussion about
the the unwritten rules and
civilizations surrounding
dialects code switching you know what
it's like to be for
example black and to speak black
vernacular and to have white people
attempt to do it
anyway another conversation that was
very generative and didn't fall apart
over the
um the the triggers that caused these
conversations to be
so difficult in modern times so what i'm
hoping
is that people begin to recognize that
we've lost ground recently we've lost
the ability to discuss things we used to
be able to talk about
and that they miss it and that
resurrecting that is
highly valuable so yeah anyway i think
clubhouse is still uh in a
closed beta and so you have to find an
invitation either from somebody who's in
there or maybe you can email them
i don't know when that changes but i
would be very interested to see people
who
are excited about uh finding those
conversations
join and reinforce the desire to have
them because
without them i mean we've seen just
catastrophes
uh across social media and in the world
yeah well actually so i'd forgotten that
i wanted to read just uh two paragraphs
from a letter we received
um which i think that's a good segue
it's a little bit less hopeful than what
you were seeing in in clubhouse but
um from from a different perspective so
this is dated november 1st
um and i'm just two two paragraphs from
this from someone who
um who wishes to remain anonymous last
night i went to the trump rally in
butler pennsylvania
which you can read about online i
originally declined to go because of
fears of cobit 19
because i'm not a particularly fervent
trump supporter i'll vote for him but
i'm keenly aware of his many flaws
yet in the end i did go and the letter
writer talks about the various risks of
covet and how concerned he is
and asks why did a highly risk person
person
why did a highly risk averse person like
me go
two reasons that morning i took a walk
with a very good friend
he said that he would consider going to
the rally but if a camera panned the
crowd and someone from his workplace saw
him
then his career at a quasi federal
agency would be ruined
this put into clear focus the dangers of
the current council culture of which you
frequently warn
i realize that we as a society face a
risk of silence through intimidation
this is not the country that i love
where people can express their beliefs
whether i or anyone else agrees with
them or not
so i went to that rally for my friend
and people like him as a small act of
courage and defiance to defend the first
amendment
and it goes on but i'll i'll stop i'll
stop there i mean he also ends up going
for his son
um for whom he wants to demonstrate
um some courage and um and that he is
willing to
stand behind you know his beliefs which
in this case you know he says i don't
i'm aware of the many flaws of the man
and i'm reluctantly voting for him but
i felt that it was important to go to
this because many people
can't because of fear of retribution
and so what you're relating hearing
in that room in clubhouse a conversation
that include what did you say
race and economics and class and
politics maybe
i think i feel like that's not just
certainly true but yeah
um seeing seeing people
not go off the rails and seeing the
conversation itself not get derailed uh
is
possibly the most hopeful thing i've
heard
in a while yes the other thing which i
think i'm failing to convey
is how much it became clear amongst all
these people who
almost none of them know each other
right a
kind of camaraderie breaks out because
people
realize that the room is feeling a sense
of
it's feeling emboldened it's feeling
relief
it's you know it's br it's breathing
after holding its breath
and this is so powerful that i really i
don't know if there's anything that can
be done to preserve it or to augment it
but if there can
i think it's important now that said i
will
caution people it is very easy to waste
time in clubhouse as it is on all social
media
and it is also difficult to integrate
with your life because
unlike something that you can just
passively read and
type you know you're you know just as
you don't want to be on the phone
in a room with people who aren't part of
the conversation
it's disruptive so anyway yeah you were
particularly thrown when the two of us
were making dinner
one night and you were you were on one
of these things because you
you were on your headphones like i was
actually okay with it i was almost done
but in general yeah when we're when
we're in the kitchen together
i'd rather you not be in some world
wherever it is
so anyway use with caution but if you
can get in there
and you know it also takes a bunch of
hunting to figure out which rooms
are generative but i've now seen good
examples i've also seen people
um use it for interesting novel purposes
so it has not yet figured out what it is
and that that makes it more interesting
than
than other such things so
join us on our patreons where there's a
discord server that you can
um join for conversation as well not
audio
but text uh we have a
private q a once a month uh for uh
darpa's members at my patreon and brett
has
more intimate conversations at his
patreon every month
we have a clips channel now where you
can find clips of various things
and we answer your questions in the
second half of this show as
the vast majority of you already know so
um put in a super chat we are going to
get a replacement for super chat online
soon that doesn't involve going through
the google youtube machine
yes and early indications are that it
will be
vastly more awesome yes yes
absolutely vastly more awesome but for
now we're doing super chat
so pose your super chat question either
now or at the beginning of the next hour
and we'll be back in about 15 minutes to
answer your questions for about an hour
all right be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you